[Music]
we didn't neglect the Jewish viewers
Luke sweet Chanukah much
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the CrossFit for
your brain can I be honest when I first
heard about CrossFit I thought it was
like a cooperative board game or
something all right all right let's talk
Marvel and Netflix we all love Marvel
movies right as evidenced by all the
requests that I get from you that is a
pretty solid yes and 2017 is gonna be an
awesome year for them guardians - and
spider-man I cannot wait what over the
holidays I took some time to catch up on
the rest of the Marvel Universe you know
the guys who are still waiting for their
crack at the big screen and without
question the biggest of those guys is
Luke Cage now over here in film Theory I
don't know if you've noticed it but I
didn't have an obsession with trying to
kill superheroes and be brought down by
a simple bullet destroy the brain and
Wade Wilson as we know him ceases to be
once warden Superman won't know what hit
him
oh man looking at that if I wasn't me
and I saw that I would be very concerned
about my mental state but luckily I am
me and all murderous sociopathy aside
maybe it's just my long-held desire to
be a supervillain or quite simply maybe
it's my desire to be able to beat Braun
with grains or maybe I just want some
compelling but ultimately honest
clickbait I am not really sure probably
some combination of all three of those
things what I am sure about though is
that one superhero safe and that one is
Aquaman because your powers suck way to
put innocent marine life into the line
of fire for you but enough about Aquaman
because sweet sweet Christmas Luke Cage
today it is you who has drawn the short
straw in other words it is time for you
to meet my Lucille well it's actually a
metaphorical Lucille because literally
hitting Luke with a barbed wire bat
wouldn't have any effect due to his one
superpower impenetrable skin that's
right throughout Marvel's Jessica Jones
and Luke Cage Luke is routinely shot
stabbed blown up shot again stabbed
again and blown up again but all of it
has no effect on Luke he's like a steel
electric-type pokémon he just walks away
without a scratch daredevil was
bedridden half a season two because of a
couple of punches and Jessica Joanne
received her fair share of scars but not
Luke the villains of the series
cottonmouth and Diamondback have to
literally resort to alien bullets just
to have a fighting chance against the
guy
so this got me to thinking is there a
simpler solution here than just magic ET
bullets what if everything you needed
was right here on earth at your very
fingertips well get ready Luke cuz the
rise of dr. theory is upon you hey I
said I wanted to be a supervillain okay
I didn't say I had a good name picked
out yet evil mind no anti Pat knows
nothing never mind so like I said
ultimately all of luke cage's powers
boil down to one thing
his skin skin made out of three layers
measuring two millimeters thick and
creating one impenetrable body and
that's it get past that outer wall Cena
and he's just as vulnerable as you or me
as we learn about at the end of Jessica
Jones after Luke takes a shotgun to the
face the whiplash from the shotgun blast
causes Luke's brain to slam against his
skull putting him into an immediate coma
so to take Luke Cage out we just need to
get to those squishy innards of his now
throughout season 1 of this Netflix
series every single villain has focused
on piercing Luke's two millimeter
fortress of protection via knives guns
rocket launcher shotguns alien bullets
like everyone's been looking at this
from the wrong perspective the focus
shouldn't be on breaking through Luke's
skin but instead lowering his defenses
from the inside out turning his enhanced
skin back to what it once was regular ol
easy to pierce please don't look at my
saggy love handles human skin and in
order to do that we need to look at his
origin story now before Luke Cage was a
superhuman with the toughest skin on
earth he was just your average guy with
normal skin and horrific facial hair man
Marvel I know your budgets aren't quite
the same for the Netflix series but geez
it looks like you glued a chia pet on to
his chin anyway while in prison Luke
Cage is beaten nearly to death after an
altercation with other inmates
he's only saved with the prison doctor
dr. Burstein performs an experimental
treatment on him resulting in his
impenetrable skin later on in the series
dr. Burstein actually reveals the source
of Luke's superhuman abilities
Luke's chemical composition his DNA has
been fused with the foreign DNA of an
abalone we used a process called CRISPR
diffusing subjects DNA with another
no believe it or not but this crisper
process that dr. Burstein mentions is
actually a real thing
CRISPR stands for clustered regularly
interspaced short palindromic repeats
it's a very real process wherein
specific stretches of genetic code
target and edit DNA using the enzyme
cast nine scientists cut out specific
strings of DNA and replace it with
whatever the heck they want it's
basically just like what happens in
Jurassic Park except real in real life
the end result is that scientists can
modify and enhance genes in cells to
make them better in China researchers
have successfully used CRISPR to create
extra muscular dogs for hunting and
military purposes
damn you China and your mutant dogs and
what is the u.s. done with this amazing
scientific innovation well we gave Luke
Cage the power of delicious seafood our
DNA was a millennial isn't it yes an
abalone it is a snail that lives in the
sea a sea snail now I make jokes because
that seems lame but abalone are actually
known for their incredibly hard shells
abalone nacre the shells are so strong
in fact that students at UC San Diego
are now using them to create body armor
tougher and stronger than Kevlar but it
doesn't stop there abalone is just as
strong as steel and can even stop
bullets
so maybe Aquaman's powers aren't so
silly after all imagine him having a
team of impenetrable shellfish as
bodyguards all right on second thought
it's still really dumb speaking of dumb
Aquaman's hair go get some conditioner
because the sea salt is really starting
to build up there buddy so one method we
see in the show is eroding what makes
the abalone so strong
dr. Burstein implements this tactic when
trying to remove the alien shrapnel from
Luke's body in a series of acid baths
per dr. Burstein abalone on its own is
nearly impenetrable a shield of stacked
calcium carbonate plates by destroying
the hydrogen covalent bonds between
those plates he can actually break
through your skin cells were bonded with
hydrogen of covalent bonds at the exact
point of acidity temperature and saline
concentration now before we go any
further for those unfamiliar a covalent
bond is a super strong chemical bond
that pairs electrons between atoms
strengthening their outer shells and
stabilizing them basically think of a
covalent bond like a marriage too hot
single young atoms catch each other's
eyes from a
the molecular field recognized that they
need the other one to fill a hole in
their life or at least their valence
shell and a few rounds of netflix and
chill' later they've formed a tight bond
a tight covalent bond now in order to
perform surgery on Luke Cage dr. bursty
needs to break those covalent bonds dr.
Bernstein is basically the husky from
across the street trying to horn in on
your man homewrecker after you gave all
your atomic energy to that no-good
cheating husband of yours it's like an
episode of nerdy Jerry Springer to break
up the bonds the doctor recreates the
exact same circumstances that caused
Luke's powers in the first place and
scientifically speaking this is
completely the right approach the only
way to break a covalent bond is by
recreating what caused the bond in the
first place so way to go Luke Cage
riders you have done your homework
unlike others so to break those covalent
bonds that bind you you have to match
the same amount of energy needed to form
the bond in the first place for Luke
Cage dr. bursty knows the reactants that
formed Luke super skin acid saline
Luke's DNA and abalone DNA but he
doesn't know the amount of energy needed
to break up that product
the doctor says as much in Episode nine
well car is the temperature quite simply
bursting is unsure just how strong the
covalent bonds are in Luke's body and
dips him into higher and higher
temperatures of acid baths to find the
level where there's enough energy to
break through Luke's skin but not so
much energy that it dissolves him alive
you know that might be bad now obviously
this is ridiculously complicated but
I've got to tell you there's a much
easier way to defeat Luke Cage one that
doesn't require acid or the existence of
aliens with killer ballistics consider
this given the controversy surrounding
human genome splicing geneticists have
created ways to reverse the CRISPR
process you know in case all this
genetic meddling leads to some sort of
less than desired effects like a
three-eyed fish or someone who looks
like a Red Skull or something so the
true secret to beating Luke Cage is to
reverse the CRISPR process but that's
got to be really hard right oh it'd be
surprised so scientists typically
reverse these effects using what's known
as restriction enzymes which are kind of
like super selective scissors for DNA
it's
instead of cutting paper and forming
origami flowers you're cutting into
human DNA in forming super human flowers
each restriction enzyme recognizes a
particular DNA sequence and cuts out
this sequence within the DNA thus to
reverse luke cage's powers all you have
to do is cut out the foreign DNA that
abalone nacre sequence from the source
DNA Luke Cage turning him back into a
mere thin-skinned mortal so at this
point you might be saying to yourself
well Matt that doesn't sound a whole lot
easier than dipping him into an acid
bath where do I get my hands on
restriction enzymes for abalone maker to
which I say to you Google and it's only
58 bucks
like Black Friday all over again but
then how do you get all of this into him
I hear you asking they can't even cut
into his skin so what chance does a
needle have to which I say to you none
no chance in heck a needle is not the
way to go besides if you simply injected
the restriction enzyme into Luke Cage
his immune system would immediately
destroy those foreign proteins and Luke
Cage would probably destroy you for
trying to stab them with a mysterious
needle however I've thought of that and
scientists have already discovered ways
to break through the human body's
natural barrier system and the answer is
viruses through a process known as viral
transduction scientists package foreign
DNA into a virus and then expose it to a
cell once a virus binds to the living
cell it injects the foreign DNA into the
host and then replicates this DNA
throughout the body think of the process
like a Trojan horse where a bunch of
heavily armed soldiers sneak their way
past your cells defensive gates but I
already know what you're thinking how do
you get your hands on a virus I mean
it's not like you can just go online and
purchase the common cold off the
internet yep you too can have your very
own common cold virus get your entire
school a sick day by releasing viruses
throughout your classroom just a couple
bucks off Amazon Prime so with your
ingredients in hand do a pen pineapple
Apple pen I have an enzyme I have a
virus
fibrous enzyme I have to do is splice
the two together and ah voila you have
the perfect cocktail to defeat Luke Cage
and the best thing about this virus is
that it's airborne you don't even need
to attempt to pierce luke cage's skin
just invite him out to the local Java
Hut get two cups of coffee laughs over
what a terrible lawyer Matt Murdock is
and then finally wait for the sign that
the airborne cold virus you've exposed
him to in the cafe has taken effect
turning his impenetrable skin back to
normal just wait for that first sniffle
and stay another superheroes head to
mount on your wall it's a heck of a lot
better prize than Aquaman and with that
rain three wrong zero but hey that's
just a theory
Oh film theory and cut also a very
special thank you to the team over at
the wisecrack channel for helping me
with the research for this episode if
you enjoyed it then please do me a favor
and also yourself a favor and go check
them out there's some of my best friends
on YouTube and where we do mostly
science and math based theories they do
theories and analyses based on the
humanities philosophy ethics things like
that so if you enjoyed this episode then
you are going to love their analysis on
my favorite current animated series rick
and morty legitimately one of the
funniest smartest shows on right now and
their analysis of it is one of the
funniest smartest videos of that show
online to pull a Luke Cage and punch
that button you see on screen to show
them some love and find yourself a new
favorite channel and make sure you stay
tuned we have a lot more Marvel on the
way next month so ahead but that
subscribe button to join the
notification squad gotta go see you next
week